the Joe Rogan experience well I think I
think running off your toe is great yeah
I mean there's something as though the
who chose the running who doesn't who
who does it I do I run with minimal
issues yeah and I mean who knows they it
fortunate standing bike that is
ridiculous
I wouldn't be caught dead in that thing
well good night for me that that there
that's the elliptical they have the new
a new one that's just a pedal I'm just
kidding it looks awesome
no but you know I think I made that
silly because the guy was a runner and
couldn't run anymore got injured and
then he said he started the bike and he
said biking's not running and so then he
developed that thing because it's
simulates running without the impact
that's unlike I said that's why I like
the pool that's why and and I think too
it's like if you think about doing
things forever mmm we're talking about
doing things forever
yeah right yes so we're talking about
doing things forever so how are we gonna
do them so we can do them forever no
impact so reducing impact and if you
actually started doing that initially
then you might not have to worry about
trying to recover from all that stuff
that you so it's like we don't want to
Train in a way that we're gonna have to
change our training to try to make up
because all the damage we've done let's
try to avoid the damage from the
beginning and I'm it's already too late
for me I got seven you know I got six
broken ankle seasons I got broken
what the hell did you just do your ankle
is what's been program six or seven
times broke the arch broke all the meta
to stream surfing all different
motorbike surfing snowboarding does you
mess up your hip probably cuz my broke
walking on a broken ankle for all those
years because each time I broke it I
have five or six different breaks and
then I would keep going
so I would keep walking on it and but
I'd means I had to carry the load on my
right hip so I think I just wore the
cartilage out from offsetting and
carrying the load of the broken Lake
Jesus so that was but so I mean it's so
it wasn't like one injury where you hurt
your hip it was just slung I just wore
it out I just I I said I lived a couple
lives with Helen oh is that that was
only a one life hip and I had three
lives in a
what does it like having a fake hip
insane incredible Bionic the things not
even in my in my in my brain not even
how so it doesn't I doesn't I I don't
ever even bring it in into consciousness
it's an its slicker it's like a
mercedes-benz ball joint I mean it's
absolutely perfect Wow
it's a and and you know I mean I've had
ACL I had some nice stuff before that
was harder to recover from than the hip
the hip was I just felt like I got
kicked by a horse for a couple months
and then after that it was like no
brainer jump off a cliff go stand up
paddle run I mean I'd tell you to not do
certain things no really no you could
like you could just start don't do
anything you should do with your real
one oh really that's done doing anything
you shouldn't do with your real one yeah
absolutely
that was the only thing I mean the guide
the doctor Penenberg who did mine he did
it to a contortionist I guess some
contortionist had some blown hips and he
did it to the girls still performing and
stuff so I don't I think it's I mean the
stuff is the technology is amazing and
the thing that I the thing that I would
consider if I ever had to do it again is
that the atrophy from the the the the
initial problem is harder to recover
from then you just go in and get in the
new one and I think when people push it
you know they used to try to push that
stuff because they want to wait for the
technology got better and they only last
15 years and all that stuff but the
atrophy that you try to recover from
it's harder to recover from than if you
would have gone in and gotten it done
when you need when as soon as you needed
to have it so the one you have now you
have to get it swapped out every 15
years no no no but but in the back well
they do they they don't know how long
this new stuff lasts they had some they
had some material that that wore out
after like that because there's a like a
some kind of polyurethane some kind of
psychic outer layer well like a cart lit
like like a man-made cartilage between
the ball joint in the socket and so that
stuff wore out in the past but they out
and they have this new stuff that that
has been in for 10
a lot of people are already and they've
seen zero we're on it so you don't know
could be 30 could be you know could be
10 I mean I I was actually uh I stayed
conscious in in I was able to stay awake
for my hip surgery uh because I didn't
want to have to recover from the from
the yeah really yeah it takes people a
month to get the anesthesia out of their
system really oh yeah to try to get the
anesthesia
I mean anesthesia controlled death there
just put you right to the edge of dying
and keep you alive I mean anesthesia
some hard stuff on your system to get
that stuff out of your organs you got to
do like a full detox cleanse it's not
just like oh yeah anesthesia I've never
heard that before I didn't I didn't know
that oh yeah I thought you feel like
[ __ ] for a day or two but I didn't know
it that shit's in your organs and stuff
there's no way that stuff stays closed
uh they can't they can't doshi out and
knock you out like that without that
stuff lingering I mean you know how long
does it take to when you got a hangover
I mean he so did they do looking up a
dural block on your have a drill block
yeah and they had it so good that they
could just isolate the left the left hip
they did that to me when I had my first
ACL surgery yeah I wanted to see it yeah
cuz I was like oh yeah I want to watch I
felt like I'm only gonna do this once in
my life I want to see this turns out add
three of them yeah surgeries but yeah
but I wanted to see it I wanted I wanted
to be there sheriff it was pretty freaky
yeah I was ACL yeah I had ACL - yeah all
the right leg yeah yeah
gabber I had a cadaver my right leg and
left leg out of patellar tendon oh yeah
yeah so now your hip doesn't even you
don't feel it you don't feel anything
not even in the wheel not even a thought
Wow not even like like amazing and it
was I was it was debilitating I could
barely walk I mean I could still surf
but I get to land I was hobbling around
like you know move and Maynard from tool
you know the band tool yeah
Maynard is a he's a jujitsu enthusiast
and he had to get his hip done and he
[ __ ] his hip up from stompin on stage
you know cuz he's always like stompin
with young leg yeah he blew his hip out
yeah well I think mines attributed a lot
to my back leg and surfing okay so I'm
on that back leg and that back leg is
loaded so I think that but but I know
the brakes the brakes and the other in
the left ankle and left foot and how
many I had and that I was always on it I
know that attributed to Locke because
this this this right leg carried the
load for that thing for him to get your
left leg fixed my ankle ankle yeah I
just let it so every time supply listen
I went I went to my knee to get my knee
worked on and the guy goes he saw my ink
on he goes and then he saw the about how
much mobility I had and he called in
some foot specialist and they had to
take x-ray they just wanted to see could
I have no metal in there there's no
screws there's no nothing I just let it
you know and just so every time do you
just let it sort of heal itself up yeah
so it snapped you just walk around on it
yeah pretty much cut the cast off the
first time was I was 16 cut the cast off
and you know and I went a tree broke it
the first time and then and then I had
broken other ways it got a little
smarter after we broke him but yeah
that's and then large dark I broke the
arch because the ankle was so calloused
so bonded that when I broke it I
actually broke my arch that was the
probably the most painful that was the
most painful breakdown in that area when
I talked to Kelly Slater he broke his
foot yeah - yes well his was just
recently yeah yeah and his was [ __ ] up
for a long time he said that's a painful
thing to snap your toes like you're the
molded metatarsal crazy well yeah you
have 75% of the bones in your body or
below your ankles what really 75 percent
like limbs of numbers yeah numbers above
but your feet your feet have like half
the bones of your entire body
god I never thought of that that's crazy
but it make there's a lot of [ __ ] down
there a lot going on a lot little little
ones in there little nubs and weird
little ankle
see that's why kickboxing so stupid you
throwing those things that people and
slamming them in the elbows knees and
stuff [ __ ] the quads big guaranteed yeah
broken nothing like kicking something
and breaking your feet yeah you know
it's a little bare
if it's a wall though oh yeah is that
what you kicked no I'm just saying no
mine was I like I said I broke mine
broke mostly sports-related motor Mike
windsurfing you know towing yeah yeah